foreign
keep an eye on the YouTube very much for
waiting
many of you are looking forward to this
game it hasn't started yet by the way
just in case
some people are confused brief Glimpse
I'm going to actually play the game for
you all today and show you what it's
like
he's gonna play the game okay
give me one sec I'm just doing some here
we are in the land of quick little
settings here and there
like The Legend of Zelda breath of the
wild there is a vast world to explore of
course it's not just the same yeah the
hype is unreal It's the final final
trailer limited if we talk about all of
the changes today
so we hope you'll seek them out for
yourself when the game launches it's not
too loud
or I'm too soft in this game actually
let me crank up the volume just a little
bit
Scott you'll notice my mic is very very
very sensitive like one small little tap
and it goes from
normal to just completely
clipping
actually I should turn it down a little
bit in case I get too excited and I blow
out all your eardrums
uh
I was not expecting to see something
this week to be honest so I I they kind
of caught me off guard a little bit
okay I think this is good
yeah this came out last month it's not
it hasn't started yet
it's
still about five minutes before it
starts still 14 minutes about uh five
minutes before it starts I will switch
to the other screen
but for now I'll just play some old
stuff in the background
I think I just made a little playlist
with all the stuff that we've seen so
far
or most of it at least
hey Trev
or how you doing
hello Sean
hello everyone
but yeah this is going to be uh
interesting I think it's
if I had to guess it's probably going to
be a little bit more story heavy since
we got the gameplay all sorted out now
I'm not sure if it's going to be on the
same level as the 2017 trailer for uh
foreign
but we will see
if it can if it can top that then it
would be
it's gonna be very hard to top that
but
I just hope it it stays true to what the
game is going to be because the 2017
trailer as as cool as it was for breath
of the Wild
it did kind of well I wouldn't say
mislead people but it
it showed pretty much every notable
cutscene that's in the game without
actually making it clear that those like
90 of them were memories
so yeah
I do hope they stay a little bit true
too like what the game is actually going
to be if it doesn't have that much story
that's
fine I guess
maybe they'll do the same thing again in
a lot of environmental storytelling
instead of Storytelling through the
actual game itself I hope there will be
more story
but yeah
I want to fuse my sword with a chicken
poor chicken
my chickens would not approve
playing nuts just uh moment ago I'm
happy they stopped sometimes they'll
just go into this frenzy where they all
start
like clucking all together and they just
I don't know what I don't know what that
what the purpose is I guess they're
calling out for mates or something
definitely but they'll just go
completely nuts all four of them at the
same time
it's like a little
durability like a sing-along that
they're doing
I have four chickens I used to have five
but one of them unfortunately got sick
and I'm happy that not happy that it
died but I'm happy that it didn't infect
the others because with chickens and
birds in general
that is a risk like once one of them
gets sick the whole Nest or the whole
Coop gets sick but it seems like it was
just something maybe they caught some
sort of cold or
I don't know exactly what it was but
yeah it was sad for instance but you
know it happens and chickens are pretty
cruel too when Once one of them gets
sick they kind of go into this
self-defense mode and they will kick
kick them out of the
out of the mansion out of the chicken
coop
so they're not allowed to go back in the
house into the nest
they have to just sleep outside
it's uh it's quite sad but yeah back to
Zelda
I hope we will get to see at least some
sort of a glimpse of it of a dungeon
that that would put that would put most
of my fears to rest about the game if we
see Dungeons and just some environments
that we haven't like that are foreign
that don't Encompass this the the
standard Overworld that we've seen a
million times now
I really hope that's the gonna be the
case that that's gonna
put my mind at ease not not that I'm
worried I'm gonna enjoy the game anyway
but
it's mostly for other people also I
guess because the whole breath of the
wild DLC argument about tears of the
Kingdom still hasn't been completely
put to rest either
Alden ring had a lot of cool
environments yeah yeah for sure and they
didn't show much
of those environments at all
like most of the promotion material was
all inside the first province
so so that benefited the the game a lot
so I get why they're not showing too
much
but they they could show like the
entrance to a dungeon without spoiling
where it is located on the map or what
what's going to be inside it or
they they can put something that's kind
of out of context but at least still
shows that it's a like clearly shows
that it's a dungeon
yeah I'm doing well I've been taking it
like a little bit of a break just taking
it easy
oh I think it could start at any moment
now so I'll just switch
Let me refresh just to make sure I'm not
behind
the toxic chat
put the volume up
in 10 minutes yeah
I'm not gonna play music in the
background so we're gonna just have to
deal with me talking over silence
because then I have to switch screens
again
I'm not very Savvy with computers all
the time
I'm bad at multitasking
great Plateau is a Skyla a skyloft from
Skyward Sword
well it doesn't look like skyloft but
skyloft could be in the game as like a
reference or something
but your editing is insane oh thank you
well
editing is a different story than like
working with I just use a computer as my
tool but
don't ask me to hook up the internet or
something well I
I did hook hook up my own internet last
time when I switched but it was uh it
was not fun
I have no patience for technology
it's like when I used to be a web
developer people would ask me can you
come over and fix my computers like no I
I just make websites I don't actually
know how computers work
like at their core
it's just a tool
yeah a lot of people think that
when you work with computers you
magically can fix them too
hey Spirit link yeah it's been a while
well you've been at Charlie's live
streams right
oh let me get to some Super Chat stuff
uh Lewis thank you so much
uh
yeah
uh you didn't ask a question but thank
you very very much if you have a
follow-up question let me know
um
oh there you go the second one Mr Don
uh you may be the best hylia tuber in
existence and your tubes change lives
well thank you Lewis that means a lot
you enjoy the content
even though I was kind of slow
with the last gameplay demonstration I
was kind of slow to work
because I didn't really have much by the
time the analysis stuff started coming
out from other people I was like well
they they already covered pretty much
anything I wanted to say I would just be
reiterating all the stuff
it's too late for me
plus nobody beats Celtic 2 the first
analysis video he's always hella quick
I'm not sure if I'm gonna stick around
for very long after the presentation
because I might start working on a video
just in case yeah you're wondering I'm
not sure if I'm gonna do a whole
analysis on stream this time
because it's also
kind of close to dinner time for me well
reasonably close I still have a lot of
stuff to do
oh thank you hero
for the memberships
midnight Naomi OG
yeah a new trailer with a crazy Dutch
guy
hype indeed
it hasn't started yet
game explain five minutes oh God
I'm very curious what we're gonna see
do you know Captain Ferguson uh I don't
know him personally but we have talked a
couple of times he's a great great guy
he's very friendly
very nice very sincere and he likes
dungeons as much as I do maybe even more
his dungeon analysis videos are great by
the way you should check him out if you
haven't already
like that that video I made about the
water temple he basically does that but
for pretty much every dungeon imaginable
I think he's at Link to the Past
dungeons right now but he's done
Twilight Princess and I guess I yeah I
think Wind Waker 2 and Ocarina of Time
obviously
oh thanks Slurpee thank you Mission
Slayer
what is your preferred editing software
DaVinci Resolve is my preference as of
late I've heard a lot of good things
about DaVinci Resolve but yeah I'm still
stuck with the Adobe package so Premiere
After Effects because it all works
together
After Effects I've just you know it's
it's in my muscle memory I know how to
work that software at best
and it has like a dynamic linking system
to Premiere so
you know it only makes sense to use both
but I I do have to say I I am
I've been frustrated with Premiere and
after effects more than once
Adobe 10 especially when there's an
update
I'm always like oh what what did they
ruin this time
because there's always bugs always weird
stuff going on
uh I think with Premiere lately there's
been a lot of rendering errors
where just footage will start jumping
around like a in a weird way there's
like these these weird glitches where it
shows just a fraction of a different
frame from the footage even though
that's not how you edited it it's very
annoying
Movie Maker yeah
well I've made my share of videos and
movie maker back in the day
uh can you please not spam the same
question uh one so
what one time is enough
there's a lot of people who want to hear
answers about things but yeah meet
arrows
I made a meat Arrow meme for HMK so the
one with uh
Tom from Tom and Jerry
it's nice
I want to see what it does
probably just added damage or something
I don't think it will have extra like
some sort of effect or maybe it'll
attract wild animals so if you do it on
a bakoblin and there's like wolves
nearby they will start attacking him
that would be that would be would be
pretty dope
narrow
oh live stream will start short I saw
something change
is it mirrors did something jump
or was it just
maybe it was just a play bar going away
yeah it did okay it did change
huh I guess it's about to start then
it's one one minute left
man I'm thirsty
I should have brought water
it's the banner below oh the live stream
will will start shortly okay
did that change did that say something
else before sorry I have a horrible eye
for detail when I'm doing stuff live
as analytical as I can be sometimes with
my videos I really
I I am terrible at improvising
I didn't even notice the Zone I charge
the first time
when we were watching the the gameplay
demonstration
one minute
I'll
turn up the volume my desktop audio a
little bit
I'm also very hyped this will probably
be the last
like actual footage that we're gonna get
I think after this they're just aside
from Twitter posts uh they're just gonna
stay silent until release
so it this has to be quite
the blowout
I would imagine if this is what the the
last bit of marketing if that's what it
all comes down to
this has to be
a game seller
yeah it just starts with zonai
that would work
it's just Zelda's face oh there we go
hello everyone
I'm AJ aunuma producer of The Legend of
Zelda series
there's just one month left until the
launch of The Legend of Zelda tears of
the Kingdom
in this vast world I love this track the
surface and Skye though you'll be able
to enjoy using your imagination to the
fullest while exploring it's not long
until you can experience this unfamiliar
Hyrule he keeps saying that unfamiliar
Hyrule I'm so very excited to see how
you'll explore this world
oh you will
you will see we've prepared the final
trailer before the game's launch
[Music]
alright then let's take a look
please enjoy
here we go
zonai
just the word zonai comes into a few oh
Skies
wow this looks good
[Music]
wow
uh the robots are fighting enemies too
so they really are just defending their
territory
[Music]
oh
new music
[Music]
oh there we go oh
I'm gonna have to analyze that
[Music]
whoa
no ruins
[Music]
finally crude
is that what I think it is
is that the arbitus grounds oh my God
the hair
[Music]
no oh There She Goes
oh my God
oh
this is nuts
[Music]
oh
that's the guy from the mural
or gallo
[Music]
oh
we rely on your night and that legendary
sword he carries
our last so it is Zelda's will be link
it is Zelda
link
[Music]
this music
oh this is definitely a a game seller
[Music]
but this has to be a dungeon
oh my God this is amazing why I am here
it's something only I can do it's a tear
it's Revival and the birth of his new
world
he
[Music]
'll eat me
but you are not alone that was read you
oh my God
Miju is much older
oh my God that was amazing
that was crazy
oh
the Champions are the new Champions are
back
you must find me so her body is
separated from her uh spirit I think I
think that's her spirit form or like
hylia form or whatever you want to call
it I think her body is in the
underground somewhere which uh
corresponds to Japanese culture a lot
in in Japanese culture or at least in
Shintoism when you die your body goes to
the underworld and your spirit stays on
Earth or goes somewhere else
so that's
I I the fact that she says you you must
find me
I think that means that her
her real body or whatever it is is down
there somewhere
a bit like spare track Zelda I guess but
not entirely
but yeah that was amazing
wait was it can I already go back
oh geez that was so great let's watch it
one more time
and then I'm
I'm gonna head out
boy
that was absolutely incredible yeah
if this doesn't get people excited I
don't know what does
it showed so many new locations new
characters new things
too much to to count
[Music]
oh I love this music
yeah hydrated Ganon is real
[Music]
ah geez this is so great
so they're not like Roots they're just
like mushrooms or something or like
tents I don't know what they are in
hatteno village
[Music]
oh
are those the wait let me I know I I
promise I wouldn't analyze right now but
I have to check just to be sure like
where is this is this near the arbitus
grounds because if it is it could be
like this has to be a dungeon right
that's a dungeon ride rising up it's
much bigger than a shrine
oh geez
[Music]
oh look at that ship
I didn't even notice that the first time
[Music]
look at the like
people are like fighting for for Hyrule
survival now like look at all these
farmers and stuff they're they're just
they're just duking it out
like Hyrule is finally
standing up doing something
[Music]
is that
Zelda
whose voice is that guy on your night
and that legendary sword he carries
is that the same figure that we see that
we saw the one on the mural yeah this
one
[Music]
oh geez this is so great
this music
what is up with this music why does it
slap so hard
like an entrance here yeah look look at
this giant entrance I think this is on
Death Mountain somewhere
zero gravity or low gravity
[Music]
hydrated again
something only I can do so I think these
are the things that we have to collect
like uh seven of them
I guess that's uh either the those
contain some sort of
Essence to restore the master sword or
maybe like holds Zelda's Spirit or
something I don't know but these are
probably the tears of the Kingdom these
are definitely the things we saw in the
mural
away you witness a king's Revival and
the birth of his new world
oh my God look at it look at him
so he will hydrate we don't know how but
he will regain his human form he's not
gonna look like a corpse for the rest of
the
taba's son
this one she also has one of those tears
on her neck
[Music]
that's definitely riju who is now older
so this game does take place at least
like two or three years after
like at least a few years has to
has passed but let me see it yeah these
are just villagers You are not alone and
there we have said on
fighting along
[Music]
and we see the
I keep pointing at the screen that's
that's not you guys cannot see that
but yeah this is uh
the rest of the mural
and we finally see that what these
things are they're just flying things
like you used to only see like the
bottom part of it and we thought like
these are Hooves or something but
they're just like these flying creatures
that we've seen all over the place
link
you must find me
like why would she say uh you must find
me if she's just because she's in Farren
you can clearly see she's
close to ground level in fahren you can
see the the fair in Province right here
so and I think this might be that
platform that we see on the mural too
where we see that figure standing
not sure if that figure I don't think
that figure on the mural was supposed to
be Zelda I think that's the the other
figure that we saw the the one that
looks like a goat
thank you
but this looks like one of those types
of platforms or something
but link could I could easily get here
so this is probably like her spirit form
or something
so when when she fell down like she her
Essence was split into two like between
her like her spirit and body was were
separated or something
I think that's what's going on but I'm
not 100 sure but it's it seems to be the
case
yeah I saw a timer
uh this is exactly what the game needed
the the final push it needed
but yeah
that was cool
that was very cool
I mean I guess we can
go through it one last time but after
that I really got a dip
we'll just uh stop in every frame or
every scene
you'll be able to enjoy using your
imagination yeah yeah yeah I know man
you can build your own little army is so
cool yeah yeah that's that's really cool
laughs
build your own Contraptions that fight
for you
so this is the stuff we've already seen
like you'll you'll see the tutorial
Island pretty soon
this music the way it started
I thought it sounded like the Lord of
the Rings uh theme
[Music]
but it it changes quite quite quickly
but it sounded like that to me
yeah he's like
[Music]
but yeah
this I think this is the tutorial Island
area if I'm
correct
might be
because here's that big building here's
that flying Cube which may or may not be
one of the mazes
[Music]
this is for sure where he runs out of
the building
in one of the previous trailers you see
him opening that big double door and
then he runs out
I think that's
I'm pretty sure that's here because you
can see this Arch too
actually this platform looks like the
same one uh Zelda is standing on it
might not be the same one but it has the
same
same design
but yeah for sure this is where he runs
out of those those double doors
[Music]
HMK is going nuts right now I can feel
it yeah
I am sure he he he does I
I'm too restrained for that but he uh
for sure will will be going nuts
[Music]
uh let's see actually let me turn down
the volume just a tad
or else it's gonna be too jarring
yeah there's like that big donut thing
that we've already already seen before
it's like near kakuriko not sure what it
does but it's there it's like some sort
of Ruin these are the things that we saw
like that I thought were like connected
to those roots
they're just like these weird mushroom
things that they built not sure what
their purpose is but
there that that's the that that's the
glowy things that we saw from a distance
like there's there's one here too and
here
not sure what they are but
they released art for Ganondorf
on Twitter or
that they post it to Twitter
I'll check it out later
I might use it for the thumbnail
uh oh yeah I forgot to check for it
yeah there's there's one of the towers
here we know there's one of those spiral
things up here too like the the towers
and shrines are approximately in the
same location where you would expect one
to be so they are Shrine uh like fast
travel Replacements since the original
towers and shrines are gone
mushrooms decorated with mushrooms yeah
look they set up stuff in inside the
castle Town ruins too
they have all these uh like tents and
Scaffolding and I guess they were
already in the process of rebuilding
they didn't get very far it seems but at
least they were doing something
yeah here's that donut thing and you can
see Rico
looks pretty much the same still oh
looks pretty similar but there's like
all these old ruins
a little about
oh geez
attack flow ruins which we already know
is no longer dark
there's the big storm which I think in a
later part of the trailer you can see a
monster coming out of it
like a giant creature
but like this for sure this is not a
shrine it's way too big to be a shrine
so
arbitrus grounds the type of dungeon I
guess I I really hope that's the case
you can see the Chica right here
so I guess this is because you don't see
Islands yet so I I guess this is when
the islands first start appearing all
the crazy stuff is happening so I guess
link just got attacked
and the castle just started Rising
and all these people are like what the
heck not again what's happening now can
we just catch a break once in a while
okay
yeah look at that
his hair is malice now
oh my God that's so cool
we get long hair Ganondorf
oh this one is similar to the one from
the last trailer but we actually see
that he doesn't make it which we already
kind of knew
that was a kind of a no-brainer this is
almost the same animation that they used
back in the day
in the 2021 teaser I believe it was yeah
2021 E3
so they didn't change much about it
except these rocks were not there or
they were like further apart from each
other
I think breath of the wild Eric Zelda
gets trapped back in
back in the time of alive Ganondorf 10
000 years ago AKA unfamiliar Hyrule her
short hair and design could be could
differentiate differentiate her I cannot
read
from ancient Prince of Zelda I'm not too
sure maybe
part of her seems to stay behind and the
other part seems to be gone
but yeah thanks for the uh the donation
uh re oh yeah renyard I I think I've
already asked before what how to
pronounce your name
it's not the easiest name to uh
to deduce but
yeah thanks a lot
Sim more sinkholes
see one of those drawings again
here's one of those oh they do have like
an entrance type of deal
so maybe they do have like a shrine
puzzle tied to them
um
I would have to check where this is
exactly
it's close to the Highlands
but yeah I'll I'll do the proper
analysis later
this is the underground for sure
not sure where but it looks like a lava
dungeon
[Music]
that's
I think there's a second chip here and a
third one here so it's not just one ship
who are these people and what what are
they doing here
does that have kind of a little bit Zone
I design
this is really cool to
reminds me of Mario Galaxy
you know where you uh
you also swim inside of Bubbles and
stuff
I think that's Mario Galaxy right or is
that 3D World
not too sure but yeah
I likey
this is also uh Mission Impossible
I did not even notice that he has a wing
suit
he has a wing suit here
so he's not using the paraglider
which is to be fair that made sense that
they would put in something like a
wingsuit in a game that's all about Sky
traversal you expect something like that
but yeah it's nice to see it
uh let me see
Stein Gregerson
tears of the kingdom is a very fitting
name because it makes me cry
that is true
well this is going to be a historic
title I think it looks like it's going
to be a very uh unique Zelda game
it's it's it has the strong basis of
breath of the wild but so much more
oh that's the shop
that we saw in the Gameplay trailer it's
like some sort of gumball machine
uh the icon for this thing on the
minimap was a shop
so I guess you can get materials from
them
[Music]
oh that's one of the labyrinths
chakra
I they don't show what's below him I
think
let's see
uh what was it again
oh
they don't show it I believe
it's just
make sure
yeah they don't show it but there is
something this was not there
wait is it upside down
might be upside down I don't know but
this is one of the labyrinths
but that it doesn't show if it's like
floating in the air or if it's just if
it's still on the on the ground
now this is the one we covered earlier
see all the new horn designs for the
goblins and people are fighting
this looks uh
shrine-esque though
this is one of those the Chica elevators
wait what does he have on him
is that the Chica slate
that is the Chica slate oh
and some sort of spool
and it's connected to the Chica slate so
is it like a Metro not Metroid like in
Metro where if the charger battery
that is this might be what inside one of
those Towers
the uh but yeah this is the new Chica
slide
not sure what it does but
here's that new figure
which I'm pretty sure is the one on the
mural has the same
rabbit ears but it looks more like a
goat here
the towers go underground maybe or it it
moves you up not sure I don't know if
this is a Zona yes or no
but we'll just have to see it I'm pretty
confident that this is the figure on the
on the mural from the September trailer
can't really make out anything in the
background I it's all too blurry
but he looks cool
or she or I don't know what it is
[Music]
here's that zonai writing again which
I'm pretty sure is not going to be
translated this looks under it looks to
be either at nighttime or Underground
Igor Ramos
that woman with the tear necklace makes
me think she's a fusion of Zelda who
also has a tear necklace and the zonai
Goat figure from the mural
I could be yeah
I'm not too sure
or it's just someone who is of that
because this has all been made by a
group of people
foreign
by some level I don't know if it's zonai
or something else but
she does look similar her fashion is
very similar
oh yeah thank you
thanks a lot
some sort of giant zonai Mech
which looks uh pretty impressive
like a Xenoblade Mech
I don't really see any details on it
but it is of the same make as the all
the other robots this one is just way
bigger
maybe this is like a test because they
seem to be like sort of friendly those
robots at least they're not evil for
sure
so this might be some sort of test or
some
some kind of uh go dot what is his name
godan from Wind Waker
which is also not evil but it's like
testing you
yeah construct I keep forgetting that
they're called constructs it's a bit of
a weird name
I just keep calling them robots
he always has four vials
not sure when when this takes place but
either you can access Hyrule Castle
pretty early on or this is before the
castle starts floating or
no wait that's not possible because he
has this Shield
Zelda
we rely on your knight
yeah that's uh
I don't know that I don't have much to
say about this some sort of weird
chamber
we rely on your night and
this is this looks like a cutscene from
the previous game that legendary sword
he carries
our last line pretty sure this is just a
flashback because we know the sword gets
damaged and the the forest is gone so
this cannot be
this has to take place like prior to it
your defense will be lit
who's the voice
um my guess is the goat figure because
we see Zelda standing in front of
that figure but yeah look the I think
this is goat guy I'm just gonna call him
goat guy for now
so pretty sure it's his voice
I'm not sure who the voice actor is
but he has the same bracelet
as as link has uh link does not sure if
he's the one who gives it to him
she has Princess Mononoke vibes
like as the the why is does she have
like a tear tattoo now
that's that
uh
pretty sure that's that motion
controlled puzzle thing that we saw
where you spin this around like a gyro
or a gimbal I should say
that's the flying thingy
still not sure how that one controls or
if it if it just Glides if you can
summon it
not too sure
but it's uh it's handy
is that a new Shield
oh no that's just a royal uh guard
Shield or I think we've seen this one
before
but he has fused it to a claymore to a
royal Claymore
so you can fuse Shields to swords as
well
that's pretty crazy
yeah fused
that's a big sphere that we saw oh here
we see those connections again between
the
the sky islands and the and the surface
and I'm pretty sure now that these are
not waterfalls because we saw waterfalls
up close
during the gameplay demonstration and
they don't go very far they stop like
only like a few
feet down from the island they just kind
of stop
so this has to have something to do with
the story or with Ganondorf or maybe
he's like corrupting these islands with
this influence because we do see that
beam shooting into the into the air
later
foreign
what is this
I'm not sure what's inside there but
this is just a cave
one of the caves what is this enemy
some sort of rolling enemy
slams into the wall
yeah those we see those same type of
rocks that we saw in Death Mountain with
the red pattern on it which I'm pretty
sure is not malice but
whatever it is it's there there's more
of them they're all over the place
one of the gut check gorons it looks
like an enemy to be fair like it has
like scales on the side of its body
or like dots
but yeah
let's see what what this is
that's tables son
this is where inside the storm for sure
and that's also apparently where the
ships are
so there's like a whole
deal inside the storm itself
this is this this is cool you can
uh what do you call that again like
escort people around
ah this music
oh here you see him using recall as a
weapon
for the first time uh well we saw it in
the other one too with the spike ball
but here you can actually see him
do it on the Fly
[Music]
really cool I was hoping to see him use
it as a weapon at some point
what's with the rocket
let's see what where is this is this
close to
yeah learning Village I think is right
around the corner here or is that even
Thai Island Maybe
might be oh yeah it's even tight yeah
yeah because you can see the coastline
here of main of the Mainland
yeah this is even tight for sure this is
like the the the corner of Eventide like
they're one of those pedestals is like
used to be right there I'm pretty sure
it's gone now but
get a rocket he's holding on to it
you don't they they don't show UI
elements so I'm pretty sure this thing
runs on battery too so it's gonna run
out at some point
but yeah
ah this is so cool like why why is it so
uh like why is there like low
gravity all of a sudden
is it because of those platforms or is
it just like
using some sort of new ability
because I'm pretty sure that it has
nothing to do with the fact that he's
high up
there's
you see Death Mountain here
the Labyrinth The Stairway to Heaven as
I stepped started calling it like this
goes really high up I'm still curious
how high we will actually go
this building is pretty damn cool
there's like a beam here
yeah it's a it's a some sort of
beam shooting on oh no it's actually
going down
not sure what it is or maybe it's just a
waterfall
doesn't matter
and here we see those are same bubbles I
think that he uses
I'm just skimming through it like uh
I'm sure I'm missing a lot of stuff
new Minecarts
yeah it's a waterfall it's just the
lighting uh the the sun makes it looks
Orange
makes it look orange
man I cannot talk today
uh let's see
what else can we do
pretty sure it's the platforms that that
are doing that
but yeah this looks like a
one of the lava dungeons or something he
also attached one of the fans to these
Minecarts we saw some of these types of
Minecarts oh they're actually Goron made
so this is inside Death Mountain I guess
because there's the Goron symbol right
here
but yeah he Powers it in the same way as
he does with the boats and the rafts and
all that stuff
and there's a construct
fighting him not sure if this is a test
or if
I mean we've seen that we we've seen
that they they are hostile oh actually
that's one of those glowing trees that
we've seen
in the underground shot
from the from the last trailer
where you don't see the character
still not sure what they are but
they're here as well I'm sure this is in
this has to be inside Death Mountain
voice sounds like Matt Mercer sounds
very similar to whoever was talking in
the last trailer the one who was all
like destroyed this Kingdom
now that that was ganondorf's voice but
um I don't know who
the voice actor is and I'm not sure if
they credited it yet but
yeah the fire dungeon in that in devath
Mountain
yeah for sure it has to be
because you can see the these Minecarts
are
are made so I guess they had used to
have like a mine down here
by the way time are you still coming by
soon or are you going to be working on
content now that we have this
[Music]
this is so so awesome like this is some
sort of like robot arm construct arm
and he's controlling it
he just built himself a tank
which is something people were already
joking about like let's build a tank
oh you are coming on Sunday nice
you are dropping by on Sunday I think
the weather is going to be pretty good
very soon so
awesome
I'll see you on Sunday then
but yeah it's it's just like
uh you can create you can create so many
cool things in this game I'm sure
[Music]
so that's
interesting like it starts as green
energy and then it
oh wait we saw that with the keys
eyeball too like it charges up
and because this is Ruby which was in
breath of wild you could use it to make
uh like jewelry that was resistant to
cold so it has some sort of Heat giving
element to it
you can use it to make fire arrows or
bomb arrows but fire arrows looks to be
more likely
what is he wearing
some sort of horn helmet thingy
wait where is this actually is this the
leneru wetlands
yeah I think so
here we see one of those batteries
that he has on the car too
so this device does have its own power
source but you do still need to activate
it
I guess maybe you can steal one of these
batteries put them on your own vehicles
and they can run for much longer
laser bomb yeah
[Music]
not sure if link is the one who built
this or if someone else did or if it's
like a security system that he's built
but it either way it looks it looks
devastating yeah this is the storm I
think this is where the Giant
looks a little bit like
Mulder rack or uh Goma
but I'm sure it's something different
but it looks awesome
might be yet another Overworld boss
is that yeah that's table sun again
I think link is also wearing some sort
of
yeah new outfit too like with all the
all kinds of glowy things on it
I hope we see Leviathan leviathans in
this maybe this is one of the leviathans
who knows
actually I'm working on a video right
now
right before release I'm gonna put that
one out there it's like the the biggest
mysteries in breath of the wild that
could be solved by Tears of the kingdom
and I've already seen like two or three
things that I can now use as arguments
too or as like supporting evidence
of course I didn't know this trailer was
gonna drop
so I was just casually working on that
one in the meantime
yeah that's quite terrifying
but that video will be pushed back a
little bit now of course because I do
have to make a video about this too
not sure if I'm gonna do a quick
analysis I think I'm going to take my
time and do
uh
I'm not sure with analysis videos I'm
always kind of it's always kind of
difficult because
I'm never gonna be the first because I'm
just not that quick that's just the
reality of it I have to play it to my
own strengths
which is the quality of the video itself
uh
but yeah I don't think I'm gonna be able
to put an analysis video up today
so I'm sure Celtics got your back and
a mass Nintendo Bandit or sorry banded
games is usually pretty quick too
although I'm not sure if he doesn't
analysis video and I think Nintendo
black crisis is going to do the same
thing he did last time just a couple of
days after everyone else but it's going
to be like super detailed
but we'll see we'll see
I'm just gonna keep going over this
footage after I I ended the stream and
see if I can find something to do
I might just do a regular analysis
but then it's gonna be a couple of days
from now
we're doing an analysis now anyway so
even though I said I wouldn't
why I am here
let's see if there's is there anything
different that we can see
that would suggest that she's in the
past or I don't think she is but
that's one of the symbols
that's also on the pins I think
oh
foreign
yeah here's the corpse
I guess the yeah yeah he's doing the
the YMCA way points upwards
there's art of Ganon on Nintendo
Europe's account like Twitter account
hold on
oh let me check it that one out oops
uh
let me see
Nintendo of Europe I will switch to the
other screen soon uh Nintendo of Europe
there we go
look at him
whoa he's buff
I think when we see him in the trailer
he's still like
he's still recovering because he did not
look this buff at all
but yeah he looks badass look at the
hair I like it I like his design a lot
but I I think like he might gradually
start restoring himself into this form
because he doesn't have the like flowing
malice hair here
but yeah this is uh this is great I'm
gonna quickly save this one to my
uh videos
trailer analysis
assets
again and oh
there we go
but yeah he looks cool
I don't think this is underground
I think this is later this is not the
moment he attacks link
there's a tear on his forehead
let's see uh oh wait I have to go back
to the Twitter
is it
isn't that just his Red Jewel that he
always had
foreign
of course I cannot zoom into it like
that
hold on
I think that's just this Red Jewel that
we've seen
in all the other footage too
although it was yellow in that one but
you can even see in the comments
oh yeah that's true uh
wait who said that
uh
someone said something about the Sky
Barrier
where is it
someone said about something about this
Sky Barrier being gone I think that
could could be this yeah
where he's like lifting the barrier
that could very well be the case yeah
does you do you do see like some sort of
pattern
so he's breaking through the
he's like breaking through the highest
barrier
and I guess that's when the the islands
start showing up maybe he really does
just want access to the Sky Realm so it
might be the sacred realm or related to
it
uh again increased the height limit
oh that was Spirit link who said that
about the barrier
this is just your typical
Lino stuff
this might be a new design for the Lino
although not sure no I think it's just a
blue liner but they do have different
horns now like all the other enemies
which I'm sure you'll be able to use as
a weapon
so this is where the master sword gets
smoked
you see the malice traveling up his arm
man that looks painful
he he is pretty buff here too so maybe
he just regenerates pretty quickly yeah
look at him
man's been working out man
to be fair he usually wears an armor so
we don't see those those pecks very
often if at all
I think the long nails is just because
he was a corpse like the it's not
necessarily that the
the nails are long maybe but more so
like the flesh around it is gone so they
look longer
sorry Daddy yeah
he looks awesome look at him
his Jewel does light up
but I'm not sure if that's the same
thing as those tears
not too sure
you don't really see it
does look look like some sort of sacred
energy
the yellow stuff that we see often
wait oh I'm going too fast again
wait
is this the great plateau
I think this might be the great Plateau
yeah you can see the broken wall here
but what is
this part then I don't remember that
I don't remember this being on the great
Plateau because this for sure is the
damaged wall
so he's close to the Temple of time I
guess
maybe there's just new structures on the
the grape plateau
yeah you don't they don't show you what
I'm pretty sure it's just this Jewel
ganondorf's Clothing Design looks like
the same as Link's new toga clothes
maybe it's ancient zonai again with the
time travel Theory sorry no that's okay
renyard I'm not sold on time travel just
yet uh I think there's an equal chance
that it's just going to be we're going
to see certain flashbacks of ganondorf's
pass and what he's been up to over the
past tens of thousands of years but I
mean
my words are not
like it doesn't mean anything because we
it's all speculation anyway
but yeah he does have the same uh which
the corpse was also wearing that same
outfit with the open shoulders and stuff
so maybe this is just after he revived
I I do I do love his design though
he looks so awesome
I think he's gonna actually do much more
this time he's not just gonna sit in
inside his castle and just chill out
yeah he looks like a a mix between Wind
Waker and uh Twilight Princess
he does still have the round ears by the
way
which is weird because uh Twilight and
not Twilight Princess I think both of
them had pointy ears
I guess I changed up his design again
because
after
uh Ocarina of Time he stopped having
rounded ears
he's only had 20 years
what is this creature
looks a bit like a dadongo
foreign
oh that's that other person they were
talking about yeah
I don't think she has anything to do
with Zelda aside from that she's from
the same tribe of people that this the
sky people
I think she might just be
yet another character some sort of sage
or
not too sure but
I don't necessarily think she
has anything to do with Zelda like it's
a fusion of Zelda or something like that
she could be his own eye yeah
her uh Aesthetics are are very similar
she also has the tears here
I think Zelda only has one
they all have something on their
forehead I also notice
including Ganondorf himself too
and they have the Lotus earrings
but yeah she's clearly magical she's
powerful
the queen of Hyrule that would be pretty
cool although she's pretty much been
dead for hundreds of years right
a hundred and
16 years or something
wait are those
molduga she's zapping or let's see yeah
those
those are my modugas so that horde that
we saw the the horde of modugos that is
somewhere close to the uh gurudo Canyon
I didn't even know what those were the
first time I saw the trailer I thought
it was just dust clouds whipping up
because if something was rising from the
from the ground or something
but yeah it's totally
a horde of molduga or a flock I don't
know how do you how how would you call
or what would you call like a group of
molduga
because they're kind of like Giant
seals
a herd
a menace yeah that's a murder of molduga
that's even better that's from crows
right A Murder of Crows it's such a
weird thing that a group of crows is
called a murder
a school of moduga well they're not fish
although they they do swim through sand
so who knows
and there they all go they go flying
she inherited the the lightning powers
so now that
I'm happy the other Champions are dead
well that sounded wrong I'm happy they
stayed dead after the game and these new
characters are gonna take over it would
be very stupid if they suddenly like oh
there's King Rome again he's back from
the dead after they finally were put to
rest
all right
like I do think death should at least
have some some consequence
but yeah she's now wielding the the
dual blades and she can use lightning
power and she's clearly a bit older so
she's going to be a very cool
replacement for
uh
uh oh god
um
my brain is uh
Sages
uh no I don't think they will be yeah
oribosa
why do I keep blanking on names it's so
weird
she's my favorite Champion too
[Music]
this guy yeah
he's got a bucket on his head he's gonna
this is this is the guy who's gonna save
Hyrule for sure
it is cool to see uh Hyrule fighting
back though
and working together because we see uh
different races together
but
a Zona sword
that's a that's definitely a new sword
I haven't seen that one before it's
quite short
sword a Bucket Man
Mr Bucket
yeah so are there gonna be like missions
where you work together I think it's
probably going to be a bit similar to
the how you got into the Divine beasts
like there's just going to be a story
section where one of the the Champions
or
in the case of tabai's son we'll tag
along and
help you
overcome something
this construct looks cool
like a shaman
and they're gonna be working together
too
we haven't seen I'm missing someone
where's unobo
what is your nobo doing
why is he not here
also what what this side on have on his
hand
you didn't I don't think he had that
before
it's got some sort of Jewel here
but yeah where's unobo
I know he wasn't the most Brave
individual but come on man
don't do him dirty like that it's like
I'm just gonna stick stay behind guys
someone's got to go look out for the for
the other gorons
there's glioch
so this looks like a cutscene I'm not
sure if this is just staged or
if it's going to be relevant to a story
thing too I thought he was just going to
be some sort of weird
uh random Overworld encounter
something you can just run into but
maybe there is like a cutscene tied to
it and it does have something to do with
a dungeon or the story progression
but she has the master sword here
see she also has a the head thingy
they all do
but she only has one tear
on each under each eye
I mean
it seems to me like they are like Spirit
beings then if that's the case
but we'll just have to wait and see I'm
happy it doesn't spoil too much
as cool as the the trailer the this
trailer itself is
the story is still pretty much intact
when it comes to the mystery
sidon has a crown really
didn't he already have something like
that before you are not alone
oh yeah he does have something on his
head
oh yeah he totally has the crown that's
dorofan's Crown so the Dora fan like
did he kick the bucket
in the Years After
like I'd say there has to be at least
two or three years maybe even four
between because Richard she doesn't look
that much older but she is definitely
older for uh for sure so I guess he he
became king maybe he just abdicated
he does does it yeah he retired he
stepped down
doesn't have to be dead
they don't show the bottom part of the
master sword here I think no
I'm sure it's damaged it's the the
broken version of the master sword
because I think the sword will probably
be broken for the majority the majority
of the story
if I had to guess
that's it
that's a new sound
uh Tim is gonna have a great time
dissecting the music for this
Zelda repairs it
I don't know
if it was that easy then
I don't think
that would be much story
he kick but Bucket Man
yeah my bit might just be the tears that
help restore the master sword in some
way
what is
if that if that's Farren
what's this then
is that
way
if this is Farren
this cannot be Central hero so this has
to be
a new Island right
yeah I think this
this has to be a new island or a new
landmass a new Province there's even a
building here which I don't do not
recognize
I think this is the north uh like facing
north
so like if you go around the corner here
you would get to lurlin Village and that
like Peninsula over there
and even tied
so I'm pretty sure this is a new
island off the coast like
let me see if I can find a map real
quick oh
uh
do we have Maps here oh wait I
yeah they have like this interactive map
with the world map
yeah there we go
hide all
the icons
I'm pretty sure this is like what we're
seeing is this side so there has to be
like some sort of new landmass here
if I had to guess
so this is like
uh damn this is hard to do at the same
time but I'm I do not recognize this and
this looks like ocean
like if this was like in Hyrule itself
you would see more Mountains and stuff
like that in the distance
so we got Skye we got underground and
there's gonna be completely new land
masses too
huh
it's just DLC bro
if people are still gonna be making that
argument after this I'm gonna be very
upset well actually I'm not gonna be
upset I don't care let people be
negative but
look you can even see like water boiling
up here
I don't know why must
find me
oh no it's not coming on the set it's
not coming out on the same day anymore
we use different dates here
like this would be the fifth of December
in in Europe
wait this is Nintendo of America right
yeah it is
we have Day first then month
which is better it makes more sense
oh this was the leaked uh thumbnail
I
thumbnails leaked
day month year yeah it makes just makes
the most sense just
you go up you get bigger units
glider
still wondering what these malice holes
are
they're going to lead to anything or if
it's just
a dad
oh wow we've actually been streaming way
longer than I was planning to
man I'm gonna play it one more time
without pausing it
just for the fun of it and then I'm
gonna dip
get ready for dinner and all that kind
of stuff
yeah
dude
thank you Pine
you are the best too
I can keep watching this for the rest of
the day easily
foreign
I love that instrument so much that they
use for the Dragon theme too
that one is way more prevalent in in
this one and since the dragons are
spirits those new people that that we
see those those Sky people might be
Spirit beings too
or spiritual people
she's
I already wanted to I almost paused it
to check something out
yeah the the air who
[Music]
yeah I think it might be the Arbiters
grounds or some sort of dungeon I'd I'd
have to check out the environment see if
it wow
this guy looks really badass
but yeah I will be analyzing the the
crap out of this whole thing
Zelda
try to find the exact the exact
locations
our last line of defense will be link
[Music]
he also has one of those jewels on his
hand
the one like like the same one sidon has
on him
the Mr goat guy
this music man oh my God
so awesome
but yeah dungeons are pretty much
confirmed uh hydrating Ganondorf is
confirmed
Overworld bosses
[Music]
and the birth of his new world
The Voice actor's starting to grow on me
for Ganondorf I mean
you know what I'm just gonna tweet that
out it's just DLC bro
so cool so good
[Music]
yeah see you around Clifford
Matt Mercer
but yeah I noticed the the Mr goat guy
also has one of those similar jewels
you know what I don't think I'm gonna do
an analysis video like frame by frame
because we're already we've already done
that here uh you I will keep the live
stream up
so people can just watch uh watch that
uh
but I I think I'll just do one of those
videos where it's just like 10 details
because I have to pick some choose them
like pick and choose some things that I
want to highlight
because obviously just this one frame
you could analyze every little detail on
the Overworld like oh this wasn't there
before and but
I don't know
a lot of I feel like a lot of videos are
going to be pointing out the same things
the same observations
so I guess maybe one of those types of
videos like 10 details or 10 10 cool
things you've missed click here
subscribe
Japanese has extended footage
well sometimes they will show extended
footage like on the the websites and
stuff I'll dig into that later too
anything that still comes out later
but check out the Japanese like Nintendo
Nintendo's website
let me check
uh
Nintendo of Japan website
you sure
moving
[Music]
movie
look by the way this is pretty cool
I don't know what this is on or off does
anyone read Japanese what what this what
does this say
it's gonna say on it's on
so this is the last
I think it's probably just the same
right
looks like it's the same
I'm probably going to be downloading
this version
to use in my editing it looks a little
bit more crisp than the one we saw
before
[Music]
usually I take the Japanese version
because it's it doesn't have the stupid
like e-rating and
I prefer to use the Japanese versions
oftentimes
[Music]
like where's the extended footage
Japanese Twitter has shared new Zelda
pictures that's probably the one where
like she has the
oh I'm zoomed in way too far
uh
uh yeah it's got indoor
oh
wait what
[Music]
Nintendo
I think it's just Nintendo right
[Music]
Nintendo France where the heck is
Nintendo of Japan what
I will see it later
of course everybody is going nuts
[Music]
I don't see any extent I'll go to world
like here in the background
[Music]
oh
yeah this is new
[Music]
also this is not from the gameplay
demonstration they re-recorded this
[Music]
foreign
I really like these anti-gravity
thingies
[Music]
I really like the theme for this one so
much
[Music]
I think I like it more than breath the
Wild's theme at this point it's really
grown on me
[Music]
yeah there he goes with the Little Rock
again thingy
[Music]
what is this
discovering World character
oh there he is
who else can they show
ganondor
what does this say
wait let me grab Google train Translate
uh
where is it
[Music]
there we go it's still set to Japanese I
think yeah
it says
among wait ah
the music is a bit loud
[Music]
so it says something along the lines of
among the female Gerudo tribe born as a
man
who is born once every 100 years
it seems to have something to do with
the natural disaster that struck Hyrule
do you think you think it had something
to do with that
so it just says like
[Music]
he was born
as a man in the grudo tribe
in the all-female crew to tribe
which happens only once every hundred
years although there hasn't been a
a male birth I think for a very very
long time
he has a freaking Katana yeah looks a
bit like the wind cleaver
[Music]
see what the other ones say
link I wonder what that's gonna say uh
why
can I not just speak Japanese that would
be so cool link a hero who once saved
Hyrule using the power of His right hand
he confronts hyrule's anomalies
obviously this is Google translate so
bear with me
Zelda
come on I wanna
see Zelda yeah
the princess of the kingdom of Hyrule
intelligent and full of curiosity
it gets it gets caught up in a natural
disaster that attacks Hyrule I think
they mean that means she gets caught up
again Google Translate
[Music]
so if this one's Zelda and this one is
the other one just the overview of all
all three of them yeah
we got the the original Triforce back
wisdom courage and Power
[Music]
so that's pretty cool
no more seventy dollars DLC haters
well I'm sure they've they'll find
something to complain about but you know
if that's how you want to live your life
then go ahead who am I to stop you I
cannot force
you cannot force people to think
otherwise
I I always tend to stay positive
you know even when I was still a little
bit underwhelmed
especially by uh I wasn't I was not big
on the idea of revisiting the same
Hyrule in the beginning which I I made a
complete 180 on now but back in the day
when it first came to light that we
would be going back to the same Hyrule I
was not very excited about that Prospect
but I still managed to find the positive
even then because we did see cool
underground stuff and we did we do get
the opportunity to solve a lot of
mysteries that breathtwild left behind
that we couldn't solve back in the day
like the eighth heroine and that's
something that's very unique in the
Zelda franchise
because usually it's one and done you
you get one adventure and every every
mystery that stays behind that stays
unsolved after that after the credits
roll it's
you know
it's uh
it's never gonna get answers
it's just going to be theories uh unless
maybe a book comes out that says
something about it but
yeah I was I was mostly worried that the
the Overworld was just gonna be like the
third wheel
except the sky which is new you have the
underground which is new and apparently
there's going to be new islands now too
and I thought the the original Overworld
is just gonna be wasted space or wasted
memory
but I
I don't feel like that's going to be the
case at all anymore
I think there's going to be enough
changes and as we see Hyrule itself is
revolting against Ganon
or Ganondorf I should say
there's going to be a lot of stuff
plenty to do
yeah the underground looks great so far
pretty sure the uh the lava one is a
dungeon
and we also see some cave cave-like
areas of course
uh I'm happy they didn't show too much
when it comes to environments
because I want to be surprised so not we
at least have some sort of a you know
kind of like confirmation that there's
going to be dungeon-like areas
like that building that we see rising up
from the sand in uh
ingrudo desert and we know that there's
something inside Death Mountain probably
with the Goron Minecart
so we know there's going to be there's
probably going to be dungeons because I
didn't see anything else uh they didn't
show like Shrine areas
they didn't show something that
they didn't show an equivalent to the
Divine beasts
so I'm pretty sure that they did
hint
at the the fact that there's got to be
dungeons but they didn't show much
and I hope they keep it that way well
this was the last trailer so I'm pretty
sure they're gonna keep it that way but
say there's going to be seven or eight
dungeons I don't want to know I I don't
want to know anything about it I don't
know want to know what their themes are
I don't want to know what the bosses are
I want to go go in as blind as possible
when it comes to that stuff
because that was great about Elder ring
too
just going in blind I don't want that to
be ruined
who else has pre-ordered
uh I have not actually I don't I didn't
want to play that game at least not for
the collector's edition
I don't think Alden Ring 2 is gonna drop
in July
in fact many people are wondering if the
DLC for Elden ring is even going to be
out this year
because from soft apparently likes to
take his time with that kind of stuff
with the DLC
which should be fair is always good they
always they always have good DLC
yeah exactly the DLC won't even be out
by July
I would be surprised if it comes out
this year
you were in Bandits video
what
when
possibility of time travel
of course there's always a possibility
maybe we'll visit some areas of Hyrule
in the past
or it might just be flashbacks who knows
but yeah
it's it's possible
it's Zelda so it's not like we've had we
haven't had our share of time travel in
the in the series
but if it if there is time travel I do
hope it's going to be more localized so
a bit similar like the the Temple of
Time in Twilight Princess and stuff when
the time shift zones from Skyward Sword
I do hope that
because with time travel things tend to
get complicated and you start getting
plot holes and
oh thanks Trev
thank you so much
man this turned out to be a much longer
stream than I intended it to be
I thought I was just gonna be doing it
for like uh just watch the trailer maybe
chat for like five or ten more minutes
and then head out but we ended up doing
an analysis anyway but you know
sometimes you gotta go with the flow
it was a pretty dense dense trailer for
sure yeah
I'm going to be contemplating my next
move whether or not I'm going to do an
actual analysis video a dedicated one or
if I'm just gonna do
like 10 Secrets or 10 things you may
have missed click here
the clickbaity stuff
because I I did make a like a blueprint
for a thumbnail
for the trailer analysis
I think
it's just the text though has nothing
else
it's just like what what can I put in
the background of this now that we've
seen the trailer like what would be a
good
what would be a good background
for this stuff
I can do an analysis like a proper
analysis video too but then it it it
will be
later this week probably Saturday or
Sunday because I do want to take my time
to properly go over the footage
because I notice you it's so easy to
miss stuff like important stuff
if you're just skimming through it
that's
why I usually don't do an analysis video
like right away as soon as the trailer
is over
immediately start working on on an
analysis video because
ah it just feels wrong after I'm done I
always regret it because
I start seeing so many things I could
have done better or things that I've
missed or
that's why I
did it live last time we did it live
yeah I'm gonna probably do a 20 minute
video about bucket guy
the hero of Hyrule the true hero of
Hyrule
but uh yeah
I'll see uh what I can do with this one
I'll just put something cool in the
background I'm sure there's like uh some
sort of stale frame of Ganondorf or that
that would fit this I can always change
the the color scheme too but
yeah
uh I think I'm gonna head out
and then uh start working on something I
guess
uh thank you all so much for being here
it's always a pleasure interacting with
you guys
I hope you enjoyed it as much as I did
because
yeah this was the trailer we needed
anyway I will see you all next time then
bye bye everyone and thanks for all the
super chats and all the the questions
and you guys are great you guys are
awesome
all right bye-bye
oh wait one more Super wow that I almost
hit end stream uh renyard
merging of the timelines maybe
dimensional travel or Dimension travel
we shall see man I I don't know
I need evidence like hard evidence
this has to be proven in court you know
but yeah thank you so much for the
multiple donations you made today
and uh you were just in time so
anyway bye-bye have a good one